now the day is upon us England will face
France tonight in the World Cup quarter
final Gareth Southgate believes the team
are better prepared than they were for
the tournament four years ago
up to 30 million people are expected to
tune in to watch the game the winner
going on to phase Morocco or Portugal in
the semi-finals and in the game it's
Morocco leading one nil then to the
header from Yusuf and nestri up to 30
million people as I said they're
expected to tune in tonight so it's
going to be a very very exciting one to
watch we'll be facing either Morocco or
Portugal in the semi-finals where we do
have Alistair bunkel who's in Qatar for
us now Alistair the hour is Drawing Near
what's the atmosphere like now and
crucially how prepared are England to
take on the likes of mbappe on the
French side tonight
well this is quickly addressed the
England issue a couple of hours to kick
off the England side know them killing
them the French forward is one of the
biggest threats they face tonight not
the only threat the likes of Oliver
Giroud Griezmann as well have both been
on form for France but they're going to
be scoring goals from all corners of the
pitch eight player different players
have managed to score for England during
this tournament including now Harry Kane
so they will have a confidence in their
own abilities as well but it's going to
be a tough match it's going to be a big
match and a place in the semi-finals
away a place against the winner of this
match Portugal against Morocco and well
well Morocco who are the Underdog Story
of this tournament so far who had a
shock result against Spain in the last
round well they are now one nilocks
against Portugal scoring just before the
stroke of half time we're now into the
second half it's about half an hour 35
minutes left to go Cristiano Ronaldo who
was left on the bench for the start of
the match has just come on Portugal's
back to against the wall and they'll
turn into one of the world's greatest
players but the and Pops here are full
and full of fans supporting Morocco
Morocco is the only Arab side left in
the world's first World Cup in the
Middle East and so Qatar is Morocco now
and they have flown in thousands of rock
and fans as well if Morocco hold on if
they score another goal this place will
go bananas
Alistair in Qatar thank you my goodness
it looks so exciting over there doesn't
it